it is a race for the cy young it's a
race for the national league west and
walker bueller is the right guy on the
mound responding to a tough outing his
last one really the worst one of the
year only went three innings and gave up
six earned runs the dodgers need an
another exceptional outing from him
tonight though
so bueller getting ready to work on a
bounce back he's eight and two at home
after his tough outing sunday against
the giants in san francisco first pitch
of the game by trent grisham is hit deep
to center field going back on it
bellinger he'll make the catch one pitch
one out
the reception is for manny machado
he's a chopper to third good hop for
turner
and
retired in order
in the top of the first inning on the
hill for the padres is chris paddock 25
year old making his 22nd start
first start of the season against the
dodgers first fifth of his career at
dodger stadium not good numbers at
dodger stadium he needs to turn it
around oh and two winless up there
chavez ravine with a 7.79 era that's on
to begin the game runner goes a swing
and a miss throw down and bets will be
out
strike him out throw him out double play
that'll work
it's the out in front of the pitcher
chris paddock
batting oh
29.
strike three
and panic out on strikes first strikeout
of the night for bueller
trent grisham all for one flying to
center field in the first inning
got him strikeout number two and the
side set down in order
so paddock will face gavin lux here
making his second start in left field
and it's down the line to left slicing
away from fam
rounding second and on his way to third
as bellinger is going to get waved home
here comes the relay late
one-nothing dodgers
gavin luck's driving in coley bellinger
who scores from first base
line drive that's got tremendous spin
from the left-handed hitting lux
fam really played this conservatively
and that ball bit and backed up on him
like a wedge on the tour
and bellinger with his speed he covers
ground in the outfield for defense and
he covers ground in the infield as a
base runner and boy is he put picking
him up and putting him down
mookie bets up with a runner at third
two two is popped up
center field locks going back to tag
grisham under it he'll make the catch
here comes gavin here comes the throw
sacrifice fly two nothing dodgers
andre is down two to nothing here in the
fourth inning they got the tying run to
the plate one out one out one on and it
brings up fernando
fly ball to deep center field back goes
cody ballinger he is at the wall the
ball is gone
a two-run home run for fernando tatis jr
with one swing of the bat the padres
tied the score two to two
now fernando likes hitting at dodger
stadium and takes it out of the yard to
center field for his 38th of the year
batting cleanup that's what you do you
clean them up you got runners on and
machado starts this off with an out
single to the left side and fernando
answers back
with an off speed pitch to left center
field
craig stamen into the game well nothing
more that a pitcher relief pitcher takes
pride in is leaving inherited runners
and he'll have to face mookie betts now
with the go ahead run at second base and
gavin lux walker bueller on it first
and he swings and drives one to left
center
this ball back and this ball is gone
a home
oh a mookie moment on a saturday night
home run number 20 for mookie betts as
he greets the san diego reliever craig
stamen
for the first pitch home run
two-seamer that starts away leaks back
to the middle of the plate mookie does
not miss it
this is huge you got a two-nothing lead
you give up two you've got a tie game
and you're getting close
to the late innings
victor carratini man on and nobody out
and the three ball two strike pitch
there's a bounding ball left side long
way to go for seeger he holds the runner
at second bounces it to first in time
well that is one heck of a play
out of corey seeger
down in the seventh with fam still at
second base and here's trent grisham the
pitch
line to right mookie on the run he makes
the catch
[Applause]
hit by the pitch you begin thinks here
in the eighth inning brings up manny
machado two for three
on the ground up the middle into center
field to base hit frasier being waved
around here he comes he will score
and it's a two-run game manny machado in
his third hit of the night drives in the
third padres run so adam frazier getting
the scoring position with the stolen
basin man he's just kind of feeling for
that one
not really attacking that one but
squares it up still
gets through sharply and adam frazier
will score easily
time run all of a sudden coming to the
plate here in fernando tatis jr
line to left in for a base hit manny
machado will be waved around the throw
from souza
is not going to be in time as machado
gets in and it's a one-run game
tatis will take second base on the throw
it's 5-4 now la
but here come the padres
number three and number four the lineup
tonight three hits each machado tatis jr
they are fighting back late now the
infield can move back tommy fam the
battery
fans on their feet now around dodger
stadium
kelly's 0-2 pitch
and at 9 11 in the evening on the 11th
of september the dodgers are now one out
away
strike three
game
90 wins for the dodgers
32nd save for kennedy jansen
saves it for bueller
who will pick up his 14th win rookie
bets a three run home run
provided enough for the margin of
victory tonight
with his 20th home run of the season
back in the fifth inning dodgers now
have won eight
in this series the padres have won seven
four hits again three games in a row
twice in this series and they pick up
two w's mookie betts drives in four of
the five runs to help carry these
dodgers to a w